foreign
[Applause]
here we are we might be drunk we're back
good to see you folks it's been too long
you've been on the road and a bus yeah I
don't even know who you are
a good a good friend Mike vecchione hey
Mike thank you fresh off his new special
produced by our other pal neparagazi yes
indirected by him yes and available for
free now on YouTube I'll start with a
plug and it's Killer Mike is one of the
best joke writers killer in the biz give
him a watch over a million views already
so you're late to the party get on it if
you haven't seen it yeah hell yeah Nate
land Nate land Productions I love it I
love the the comics helping Comics yes
later the party's a weird expression
because it is good to be a little late
to a party yeah oh yeah that's true the
first person at a party is like kind of
a tool all right we don't be too late
yeah the first person talks about
themselves in the third person
all right this is a good Domino's Tech
Seinfeld that bit premise late to the
party it'll be too late all right
but yeah how do you feel you got it out
it's done it's all good it's done and uh
now I'm just uh doing the other half of
the business which I didn't expect which
is um the promotional part of it we
thought the writing of it and the
Performing of it and getting that
together was hard oh yeah uh podcast
tour now and uh yeah getting Instagram
clips and getting things to go viral in
order to sell tickets well I'm sorry I
was happy to see you
so yeah this is such a chore Mike yeah
this is
[Laughter]
now we're happy to have you out here man
no but I know you mean doing the like
crushing it you know what I mean it's
like it's hard for them to do it and
then put it out and have it get seen but
unfortunately that's not where we live
now no so it's like we have to go out
and like push it and pump it and
everybody to get people to look at it
it's bittersweet though yeah because
then when people do look at it and they
it's kind of like they have to make the
discovery on their own yeah you know
it's like or if you say it or if you
have both guys say Mark Sam suggested
this and it's like now I'm hooked so
it's like them taking the suggestion and
them watching it then they become a fan
love it yeah yeah it's a [__] to do but
it's better to get the views yes they
might as well do it yes it is and you
never know you might get a new fan and
right so you got to do it right but it
does suck we're only only fan only fan
yes that's uh joke heavy
a lot of people are on that yeah only
fans is huge it's insane maybe do the
next special that way they did a roast
on there yeah
they did two rows on there
oh really well Whitney and Burt oh yeah
on only fans yeah they I think they're
trying to legitimize and go over to like
non is that a new platform that's one of
them it's either that or Reddit
ah I'm scared of Reddit yeah
I I uh one of the only thing I guess the
Creator the only fans at my show in
Miami and and Whitney just gave him my
number so he's like I got a bunch of
chicks here and I was like don't be so
only fans all the time maybe suggest a
restaurant we could go to yeah
but damn did you go I didn't we were we
were off to the next after the next gig
that'd be fun if you hooked up with a
girl and she's like that'll be 5.99.
you are an open yeah women I feel like
every woman just like sells pictures of
their feet who are these feet people
they're huge yeah they're out there he's
one
they hide in the woods
well that's more of them responding to
the demand from them right right I mean
we demand feet now I feel like yeah I'm
not I wish I was because there's feet
everywhere yeah the sandals the Open Toe
the beach this is it's it's a jackpot I
like [__] yeah you don't see that
around yeah and if you do it's never
good it's always a lady almost I hope
his wife's not listening no I mean like
I'm saying random puts you don't never
see clam out in the water all right
that's true right you know but that's
the attraction defeat though what uh
anyone what is it people find them sexy
yeah it's like another set of hands I
don't find hands that's the way people I
mean I'm a no you find a hand job yes a
hand job a foot now your foot is another
set of hands that's another one they'll
do the foot jobs are a thing oh yeah
yeah
it's weird there's foot job hand job
yeah boob job [__]
a lot of jobs
[Laughter]
we need more jobs that's what Obama said
these prostitutes are taking our jobs at
those group jobs Steve Jobs
what are we drinking here Tech bust
and welcome back beardube oh yeah you've
been all over the world he got his fill
of ladyboys and he's back for more yeah
he got
I thought you guys would all be drinking
Bud Lights
[Laughter]
I call it gender fluid
but Budweiser is still for straight guys
oh my God you got to pull up two options
this is I can't stop watching this old
ad remember the Coors Light uh twins
commercials and the twins this is what
viewer commercials used to be pull this
up Matt it's on YouTube just the uh well
wait how would you like you're pulling
that up how Jerry we cut you off
completely there oh it was awesome I
mean saw a lot of ladyboys okay it is
and then uh not not actually I stayed on
the islands but uh hung out everywhere
and like saw a bunch of stuff went to
like uh I went all over like nine
different countries wow it's awesome we
might be drunk fans
wow yeah we have quite a following there
apparently and they showed me around was
awesome we like to tie one on there you
go oh
no
we just lost our Thai fans
Taiwanese Thailand Taiwan
different right yes you just turned into
William Shatner what the hell
what play this ad real quick this is
what beer commercial used to be
yeah this isn't the ad that was like
when I was about to blow a load they
showed the guy's face
go just type in the Coors Light twins I
did that's what came up you were a bad
Google [__] I found this instantly what
year did we talk I said 2001 wow that
was when I graduated high school
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's dirty all right
it was a different time but this was not
even weird that was normal that was just
Don Draper in a room what do people like
[__] twins this is this is this is
what it used to be just like the most
pandering [__] watching my team win yeah
yeah pandering [__] and that's coarse
like can you imagine what Coors was oh
man good point dude it was uh just
football eating too much and twins they
did a thing it wasn't just football it
was a violent quarterback sacks yeah I
love that like you can see the CTE
happening right and then cut the twins
they should do one now but it's just
like [__] you don't like I hate all
these mass shootings
but I like twins
like the Minnesota Twins
damage really uh the beer commercials
went a different way yeah yeah let me
just say back to the the [__] foot
job blow job okay hand job is good yeah
foot job is good blow job good boob job
is worked on
you see what I'm saying
you [__] a foot you [__] a hand you [__]
a mouth for a [__] [__] footjob
but a boob job means you got your boobs
done right it's called a titty [__] yeah
you see what I'm saying yeah all right
yeah
yeah I think I got something there no
yeah those guys all do one is three of
them are all work for this and one is
getting is like the object you're
getting one yeah yeah it's not [__]
tits yeah where's the [__] foot it's
a good job though is a
yeah yeah all right interesting a lift
an elevator
or the opposite of uber
okay all right back to a Twist and twins
that beer used to be yeah
I I was reading about them because the
guys who made it like they're like yeah
you can't they hated it and they want it
to sound like a Limp Biscuit song like
this is like America yeah you know and
they get it's hilarious that someone
wrote that jingle I know someone's job
got paid a lot of money for that right
and they said they hated it they had
like they had a meeting I read this
article about it they said everyone
hated it and they had this meeting like
this idea sucks but then they heard all
their other ideas and they were way
worse oh I don't like to say you took it
to a focus group and everybody was like
high five chest bumping each other like
oh I guess we we saw it yeah just
[__] people in the thing yeah yeah
dude it was uh but apparently they're
like trust us the twins thing is gonna
work and it [__] blew up it was huge
it blew up you know what oh sorry it
came out it was like I think it came out
like right before 9 11 too I think it
was like early right yeah back before it
all went to [__] yeah what about Twin
Towers sorry
[Music]
what about the Real Men of Genius that
was another Bud Light and that was
killer was that Bud Light yeah that was
a really well done ass it's ironic that
that's of course like commercial that
came out during the Bush Administration
[Laughter]
remember Budweiser was the frogs too oh
that was big wiser that was like just
sloppy frogs yeah then there was what's
up oh yeah is that Bud Light what was
that or is that Taco Bell they even did
it on screams the movie yeah hanging
around commercials everyone watched them
yeah now we skip them all we are forced
to watch them you were forced and it
brought the country together
yeah
all right what do we got here what are
you doing do you remember this one this
is a takeoff of the Ann twins one okay
no this is way before you in twins dude
oh yeah it must be it's nice it's early
90s yeah I guess all these ads were the
same blew my mind when I saw it
[Laughter]
[Music]
see the beauty of this joke or this
sketch is there's no hate it's just
they're having a blast
ah
oh Farley so good
is that one word in this end
gold I think there's a tagline at the
end the Double Take the flip up
[Music]
that's Phil Hartman
I am so great gold beer is [__] it's
it's just the commercials used to be so
damn funny and now it's like what are
the commercial do they still have beer
commercials I don't know yeah
commercials but it's like Corona it's
like um over to your friends on the
beach and it's like how'd the meeting go
it's like killed it
that's what that's what like a
commercial because we used to make fun
of our roommate and dance out or we used
to make fun of our roommate Pete because
it's like oh he's a walking Corona
commercial yeah that's how he is with
his friends he's like how was the
meeting
killed it everybody cheers right it's
like that's what the Heineken ad where
the dude was just always on a boat like
every dude was just partying on a boat
like this is not connecting your average
Heineken Drinker probably no no I think
heineken's mostly black is this I think
it's a black beer yeah my black friends
drink it yeah wow same with mine they
got the same friend
Chris Allen's ears are buzzing
I was looking Che always drinks Heineken
oh does he who this is good by the way
what are we drinking Canadians that's
like a Brazilian lemonade it's just like
a Brazilian limeade so good yours is
spiked with rum that's just straight up
limeade oh it's a little bit of like
sweetened condensed milk the frothiness
is what makes it yeah yeah usually you
blend it up but I want to cause like a
Ruckus so these guys are getting drunk
and this is a sports drink
[Laughter]
you a Powerade on the rocks coconut
flavor those electrolytes in you I like
Brazilian ones better because they don't
have the [__] hair in it no no those
are just crushed up real fine
it's lovely you know for the fiber are
they [__] hairs though not in Brazil
okay they don't have hair should we do
some news hell yeah
I got some news stories cued up all
right whoa read them off sell them all
right so we have the first one is Jada
Pinkett Smith produces a new documentary
about Cleopatra claiming that she was
black history supports that Cleopatra
was from northern it says Greek but it
probably should be oh Northern Greek
descent
uh but she would have been very
fair-skinned okay what a waste of time
we're trying to pinpoint the race of
dead people from thousands of years ago
who cares just better hot we're out of
racial problems I know exactly yeah yeah
I do kind of like this though because
it's funny when it's like hey we made
this guy white everybody's mad and now
it's like all right let's make this lady
black and everybody's still mad so just
make the [__] movie you know maybe
they'll make a we might be drunk they'll
like do a doc on us in like 400 years
and we're black oh yeah
hahaha
right
what do you thinking um
I don't know let me check my uh oh
you were right I thought Cleopatra was
trans
[Laughter]
either way it all sounds like a pyramid
scheme
all right put that in the hand job if
you if you disagree with uh Jada's
vision for Cleopatra Will Smith shows up
and smacks you
like it
um Cleopatra was married to Mark Anthony
who was The Fresh Prince of Egypt
tough in movies is good sometimes you
know because in every Jada Pinkett movie
she has hair oh good point good point I
think if you check um Cleopatra did have
alopecia
her daughter
[Music]
we're rolling
all right so we got another story here a
man in China was sent into six months in
jail
uh is that scarring or scaring or for
scaring 1100 of his neighbors chickens
to death
the man identified only by a surname goo
that's gu is that his pronoun
knock onto his neighbor zong's property
and used a flashlight to frighten the
chickens in the first incident that's
only the person's in oh no this sounds
like a pretty good way to kill chickens
yeah you know because instead of
chopping their heads off or or murdering
all of them you just go in the
flashlight and they all die yeah yeah
they trample each other by the way this
doesn't make me feel bad about eating
chickens like you're a [__] dumb
animal that's how you kill yourself yeah
you deserve to be on a [__] bun can I
say that I object to this man um having
to be cooped up for six months
um I think that judge was probably a
vegan
hey that joke was excellent
it was a jury of uh three roosters four
turkeys and uh five cornish hens
yes that's a feather in your cap in
China they read the verdict like a
fortune cookie
they open it and then read it um under
Chinese law you have the right to lo
mein silent
check out the special I know you're not
very high in The evolutionary like as
animals you're like if you trample each
other humans we don't do that we don't
tremble each other to death
yeah all right when I order like a
chicken parm I always
get them back to some [__] Island
the diving
impeccable when I order a chicken parm
or something I'm like how are these
chickens killed were they afraid were
they scared to death they trample each
other that's the dish I want nice
I would pluck that one out all right
if you're still doing puns I heard he
bird flew the coop
timing you just had to wet your beak
all right do you want me to go on the
next one yeah yeah okay uh oh boy a
woman who was addicted to pulling out
and he had me pulling out
a woman who was addicted to pulling out
eating her own hair had a giant hair
ball measured 15 centimeters removed
from her stomach according to a medical
journal
yeah okay it's called a hair job
this actually happened to me too I I I
didn't pull my hair I just ate at a
diner
not Brazilian but instead what she says
because there's some food in my hair he
said there's a hair in my food right all
right that is like what is that thing
people have where they they pull your
you pull your hair out that's like a
thing there was that remember that movie
young adult yes yes I had an ex who did
that she had a ball what's that called
that's called that's some kind of a
disease some anxiety thing instant date
at Bagley Junior
when someone has a lot of hair I guess
she thinks isn't all you can eat
[Music]
all right you want to try that first
word
trica
lamania
trichotillomania there you go what about
it
before you pull out your own hair oh no
it's true it's something different when
you eat it right pulling out your own
hair and eating it and when you pull out
someone else's hair that's a world star
video
it's also funny that uh there's so many
people do this this is pretty common
yeah Show Business yeah
but they'll people eat like couch
cushion or they're like Styrofoam
peanuts oh yeah there's all these uh
documentaries about that yeah that's
just even if you eat at Subway
but then it's weird when a girl won't
blow you you're like come on
you can't blow me
what if I put my dick in the couch
this is like my strange addiction if I
put my dick in the couch I come
okay from chicken to beef we have beef
start David Cho worst question for the
pushing all right sorry uh David Cho was
slammed after a podcast detailing rapey
behavior and resurfaced uh social media
user users are questioning shows casting
in the Netflix show pointing out a 2014
podcast where he said he was a
successful rapist well at least he's
successful
I hope Netflix makes a show called rapey
Behavior so we can bring back Kevin
Spacey
I miss that guy all right he's good I
think season two of beef is going to be
called beef and broccoli
I heard they were suspicious of his
raping behavior when the casting
director said that she didn't want him
on the show and he wouldn't take no for
an answer
the show the podcast was called erection
Quest by the way
he was on a porn um show is the rape
like Netflix where she's like are you
still raping me
here's a rape we suggest next yeah by
the way this is a podcast and we played
in 14 years when we try and have Netflix
shows yeah they could have a rapey a
successful rapist section it's just
Harvey movies
[Laughter]
um so I guess what what does he do to go
to podcast prison because this is kind
of a virtual he has to resume
shows now he has to get at least 1 000
five-star reviews
it's called luminary so do you guys know
who this guy is his name is uh can I get
the joke his name is David chose which
implies consent
his body has chose
sorry what were you saying wait uh do
you know who he is oh wait we have more
oh no I'm I was just going to say that
copyright infringement is also a crime
that's what he was complaining about
that they that they posted the clip
really and it was copyright infringement
oh wow his admission of rape versus
copyright infringement yeah right yeah
he didn't consent to them using the code
so this guy Cho he's an artist and in
2008 or 2010 when Facebook started
um they commissioned him to paint a
mural on their new offices and it was
like a fifteen thousand dollar gig and I
can't remember the guy's name who the
Napster guy oh he was part of Facebook
and he said to Joe he's like take stock
and set instead and he said no no I need
the 15 grand he was like trust me take
the stock and set instead and then in
when it went public whatever year he
made it 250 million dollars that day on
that fifteen hundred dollar painting
where it was feeding so why is he still
acting
I don't think he's an actor I think they
just cast him in this oh my god wow wow
so he did take the stock he took the
stock he made 250 million wow well his
whole argument on the podcast was that
he was doing he was an artist and he was
kind of like doing I guess it was
correct me if I'm wrong he was doing a
character he wasn't speaking
authentically or he was making up a
story for entertainment reasons because
that's his that's when they people
called him on it they're like oh you're
you're admitting to a rape he goes no no
I'm I'm an artist and I'm telling a
story
from an artist's perspective I don't
know whoa yeah yikes that'd be a great
thing these guys either rapist or the
best actor
Ted Bundy was like it was a joke
I was doing a character
by the way Brando had sex with women on
film in uh yeah the Tango in Paris Last
Tango in Paris yeah and it wasn't
written into the script what he just had
sex with her right there he raped a
woman yeah that's right and he could say
I was acting or something I don't know
whoa but he really had sex with her
right there it's like when people smoke
on stage they're like that's part of the
act right so they allow it yeah weird
it's not exactly the same
I like that we all played along with
everyone yeah
a cigarette it's kind of like a sexual
assault
the Surgeon General says no to both but
that's a weird term Surgeon General I
love he tells you not to smoke but he
won't tell you why x-rays are eight
grand
it's eight grand for x-rays like smoking
is terrible yeah all right kids have a
good one
I like that it's something with landlord
it's two grand
in general you're neither it's like
lawyer astronaut
[Laughter]
s
are we got another new story here
all right uh wearable bean bags are here
a Japanese company comes up with an
Innovative solution
was this a problem before yeah
were people complaining about bean bags
well this is what Japan's better than us
because we just make our own we're just
obese we just sit on our own fat ass
yeah they have to actually strap a bag
to them that's what like it looks like
Chris Christie there yeah
it does look like they're like wearing a
fat suit yeah a little a very Gwyneth
and shallow hell yeah it's very uh Nutty
Professor Hercules
does this come with a vagina candle
you know she lit one after she won that
courtroom thing I love that she's skiing
into people more celebrities she just
ski into people yeah
we'll never know what happened it's her
it was her versus an optometrist right
yeah yeah he was some kind of a doctor
and that's great that's an eye doctor he
didn't see that yeah
they're unbelievable they really are
it's like you know people are
complaining for they have nowhere to sit
and these guys come up with the
solutions people become bean bag chairs
this is the only way you see a fat
Japanese person exactly yeah yes really
but it's like you sit on them and they
have they they tell you their own
opinions you have to listen to them
for like two hours by the way it shows
how much food we have here that we made
chairs out of food it's full of beans
it's a protein heavy seat
all right we got another story here uh
the US government is storing 1.4 billion
pounds of cheese in a cave in Missouri
yeah apparently the government has been
storing away cheese for decades even
since the 70s when former President
Jimmy Carter offered Dairy Farmers a
Break by having the government buy and
store cheese from Farmers hmm that's
what I call Brie Larson's [__]
cheesecake free all right that was a
stretch I heard they were only doing
that in like until recently they just
started doing it before that they were
storing it in a Kirsty alley I think
[Laughter]
it's okay she's dead
she'll never hear it it was a cheese
that killed her
Enigma Mountain
I heard it cost a lot of cheddar
there we go it's cheese uh cheesecake
that's what I call Swiss bank Swiss all
right well isn't uh cheese mold and
doesn't mold grow in caves so isn't it
just no why are we true the first guy to
eat cheese was pretty bold yeah hey this
milk's gone bad I don't know I don't
know if it is
I prefer hiding the cheese to cutting it
save that for the corporate gig
squeaky clean
are you doing some birthday parties they
give you one you do like a corporate gig
and they give you like one guy like this
guy likes this guy farts a lot that's a
great thing you just you're just picking
a guy for like 40 minutes you're like
but seriously your gas is a problem
you're a [__] you're a slob yeah
you're a [__] slob
this the this next one yeah they won't
let that go what is it I keep hearing
gays are causing natural disaster I've
heard that my whole life from like uh
religious people yeah what guy who says
gay guy who says God sends natural
disasters to punish gays has his home
destroyed in a natural disaster what a
horrible way to find out you're gay
uh
I think it depends on the disaster I
think you're gay if it's a sinkhole
or a Mudslide yeah
I think women are more uh prone to
natural disasters because they take your
house
hurricanes I'm gay
well doesn't a hurricane or a tornado
just blow you into another guy
good point or cow it's definitely like
it's a weird these guys like don't
believe in climate change but they see
two clouds forming they're like I guess
two women just got a back alley abortion
somewhere
right what about gays I mean you can't
blame for natural disasters because they
got the rainbow yeah so that's rainbows
when everything you know this the
Cloud's clear yeah so if a hurricane
destroys a gay neighborhood they
redecorate quickly that's true yeah the
story blows
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is
great this is crazy all right conjoined
twins Lupita and Carmen and darade I
have shared the details of their lives
and uh including the fact that one of
them has a boyfriend even though they
both share a vagina
we first of all why are they dressed
like in there in the Middle Ages
Renaissance fair
going on here this is that is crazy that
uh I mean that's like this is like an ad
for noise canceling headphones right
here
those headphones you strap them on the
sister you're like how good do they work
yeah right but he's dating one and then
not the other one yeah one is one
heterosexual and one is asexual is that
right yeah it's like having a permanent
chaperone on everything
uh they share a vagina so I guess he has
they have to schedule the days
differently it's like I get it Monday
Wednesday
and Saturday and what is the one who was
asexual use the vagina for storage
[Laughter]
one of them's a drug mule
yeah also look I I grew up with uh
sisters they can't share anything so I
don't know how that's gonna work with
the masturbating the masturbating I
guess this is like one of those cases
where like speaking of the rapists this
is where you roofie the other sister oh
yeah not your not your Dame you're
Roofing the other one yeah if you don't
want to [__] your wife's sister you're
in luck yeah you don't know how long
she's out
is this a genre of porn I don't know
incest threesomes I guess skin specific
um what are they what kind of twins are
they they are conjoined twins a
conjoined twin threesome do you want me
to look that up I gotta blow PornHub
probably away all right yeah you can
join twin threesome it looks like
they're trying to sneak into a movie
theater you know there's two of them but
they have to dress up yeah Ah that's
stuck I just want you to notice that
PornHub didn't like really on my thing
here all right
I haven't been here before
this looks all too familiar this is me
on the road with my cell phone going all
right what you'll do the job quickest I
would be so great if it just finished
typing whatever man
he put good joy and it finished wouldn't
it be great if PornHub sent you a
message just cut it out
get back to work
posted with what you've been looking up
we've never written an email like this
oh they got it conjoined twins I think
it's AI
oh come on AI anal insertion
Jesus Christ that's a mirror all right
well these gals could clean up I'm sure
this is a new it's gonna be a fetish
yeah I wish they would clean wait a
minute one pill per day for bigger size
hold on click on that click on it that's
good stuff all right this is too
distracting it's crazy that they they
share a vagina uh him
the share a [__] yeah yeah
all right German Court said that a
landlord sunbathing naked in the
courtyard of his building wasn't a
reason for his tenants to reduce the
rental payments the case uh involved the
building in an upper Market residential
district in Frankfurt uh which included
an office floor rented by a human
resource company HR
the company withheld rent because it
objected among other things to
landlord's naked sunbathing in response
the landlord sued
interesting the Nazis are at it again
make it sunbathing we'll figure out a
way yeah what's human resources like in
Germany
board the train
damn so the landlord's the one doing it
yes interesting and there's a Human
Resources company in the building oh
that's a nightmare already
that is uh that's I mean I don't know if
you
we should lower the rent but you should
[__]
you should definitely uh arrest the guy
probably right or but it's his building
it's his Courtyard right yeah I guess
jeez but it's like I need something
fixed up here and it's like I don't have
time right now I'm nude yeah you should
see the new sunbathing also that's not
great for the HR company because some
lady comes in like some guy looked at my
tits he's like hey [__] look outside we
got bigger fish to fry all right
it's a ball sack in the courtyard you're
worried about getting called uh you know
yeah and they're just so like we got the
right to do it and people just I mean
check out see we're just if you were
just a little bit hotter yeah you know
the wrong people have body positivity
right the long people are like like we
need to be positive at our body I'm like
you gotta [__] go to the gym yeah
yeah we need like hit the naked gym yes
I was in a yoga class last week and
there's a dude in there [__] it's
like a fat dude with a ponytail in his
underwear yeah and he's got a pierced
nipple and I'm like dude pick like one
of those things you get to do all those
things yeah good point yeah underwear
underwear that [__] he's got to put
shorts no one says [__] though wow cause
it's too freewheeling man we're all free
but it's weird it's weird because yoga
is freewheeling but it's very like at
least a Bikram Yoga and I know he's a
rapist
very very it's a successful rapist
he left the country actually that
documentary came out and he left the
country and now it's like I guess he's
out of our jurisdiction or something wow
I don't know he said Namaste and he went
on his way
okay so iranian-born crypto entrepreneur
Cena estavi purchased the nft of Jack
dorsey's first Davi
baby yeah baby Jack dorsey's first tweet
for 2.9 Million Dollars in March 2021
he announced on Twitter that he wished
to sell the nft and pledged to give 50
of the proceeds to charity the auction
closed selling price
279 dollars wow so that's a 2.9 Million
Dollar bath that's a hilarious auction
When You're Expecting it to go to 2.9
yeah at least and it gets 297 dollars I
know he's just up there going I don't
you know Elon Musk is like finally
someone else lost money on Twitter
not just me that'd be great if he bought
the nft
297 but you get a blue check mark
how come some people get the blue check
for and they know it's all whacked up
it's all wacky yeah because some people
bought it and then they sent it back at
something I don't know now I feel like
it's like uncool to have the blue check
yeah well because people could buy it
yeah right you had a great tweet about
that the class ring oh yeah that was
great I said basically like whoever pays
for it it's like basically the dude that
bought a class right that's great yeah
it's great I bought the class ring and I
regret it my I was like Dad can I buy it
I need a hundred dollars and he was like
you're not gonna wear it and then I
bought it and ever wore it totally
regret it yeah I remember mentioning to
my dad he was like don't buy that
[__] stuff I know I wear it now
because I'm not married so it's like I
want people to know I'm dedicated to the
class
doing donuts in the parking lot stayed
cool forever just like I wrote in
everybody's yearbook yeah I feel like
Sandler pulls up and Billy Matt with the
Camaro and the T-tops
class rings are [__] weird oh yeah
and letterman jackets too yeah I mean
yeah let's go in Florida and it's like
get a letterman jacket it's a it's too
hot too hot to wear it right and so it's
like we I got it anyway wait why'd you
go to high school in Florida
sophomore Junior and Senior year whoa I
was in Ohio and then went to Florida
sophomore junior senior year graduated
in Florida I'd say that's an upgrade
yeah yeah it's great Florida was great
man I had a good high school experience
really yeah a really great one all these
guys talk about I don't know how you
guys like view your high school
experience most people was like it was a
nightmare it sucked I hated it it's like
I loved it I loved every minute of it
it's like good people around good
friends Sports was just wonderful hell
yeah but then it's like if you have a
great High School you get it either way
if you if you if your high school
experience sucks then you suffer then
and then you got to the real world
you're like oh my God I feel like myself
yeah but then if you have a great High
School experience then you get thumped
by the real world right so it's like
you're getting it one way or another
yeah
well wait what city
Boca Raton oh man
so you're on the beach it's on the beach
it was Beach on the weekends it was
really great
a lot of juice a lot of juice good
people I said it like it's a good thing
you said it was like no I've done gigs I
love Boca Raton Florida is an underrated
comedy Place yeah oh I mean yeah there
are the the awful cities are awful but
the great cities are like like Orlando's
[__] a good crowd Orlando Tampa
the West Coast too Naples yeah I hate
Naples are you [__] kidding me dude
because it was like
an older
great
you [__] like Naples I loved it man
what else did you like uh Germany
someone's profited off a blue version of
that shirt that ain't me uh-oh I had a
sweatshirt damn
it's funny those [__] those I only
really sell them hard in like Florida
because everyone in Florida if I'm in
Florida everyone buys those but
otherwise they're like yeah but
everyone's like yeah [__] Naples I gotta
send this to my dad I'm like geez all
right
uh
don't like it wow you love Naples I did
love it yeah what's that other what's
that town above Miami Fort Lauderdale
great town great great great clubs at
the Dania Dania that's a great uh Club
Great Club Miami's a little bit of a
slug Fest because they're all hot yeah
they're too vaporative everybody yeah
everybody can rollerblade off on a shirt
that they don't like yes yes I did the
Fontaine Blue when I was there it's like
one of those like like the like Sinatra
plate here I'm like I don't think
they've updated this
in the Dangerfield so if Dade County
yeah it's like Sinatra punched a woman
right in that corner right there
people uh Sinatra's romanticize I love
them and everything but he he was just
wildly unstable
who like hit women and yeah mob ties he
was a maniac and I think he tried to get
Ava Gardner back by like just shooting a
bunch of holes in a mattress
I'm crazy without you and she came back
wow oh yeah I should try that
I worked in the 50s yeah what was the
girl passionate I'm like he's got a gun
and he's unstable yeah what was the guy
there the Rosemary's Baby the lady oh oh
uh Mia Farrow Mia Pharaoh he was 60 and
she was 21 when they were married yeah
and he was like get her out of that
picture and they were like no we're
keeping her and she like went down to
the set and raised hell then he flew out
of there and divorced her apparently
that scene in The Godfather where he's
like I've had every girl in the world
and he ruins a girl the Guy Waltz yeah
uh the Sinatra character that's supposed
to be about me a pharaoh singing lessons
dancing lessons and then your guinea
charm you pulled her away oh wow look at
that yeah yeah he's like you shouldn't
be making Hollywood movies you should be
fixing my toupee at home like a lady
yeah fun fact his dad owned a bar named
Sinatra's and he had to change the name
to O'Connor's because you couldn't have
an Italian couldn't own a bar
that's great I think that should apply
today
I think Irish shouldn't be allowed to
have restaurants yeah they need not
apply yeah
okay we got another story here
uh Japanese police have arrested two men
who posted a video on social media
showing one eating pickled ginger ginger
with his Chopsticks directly from the
communal container is that a garbage can
I kind of didn't understand the story uh
I think he took Chopsticks and he ate it
out of the communal Ginger Bowl oh okay
so it's just for everyone and you're
just eating like this getting your germs
in there I like their impolite is our
like normal way of doing this it's like
it's just accepted
they're like whoa this is forbidden this
is right right it's part of a series of
pranks of hit Sushi chains and become
known as Sushi terrorism man terrorism
there is so much lighter we are feeling
flying into buildings and blowing up
stadiums we shoot up Schools they're
like you ate the communal food you're a
monster he's the ginger terrorist our
thing would be sucker punching a ginger
person yes yes our Ginger terrorists
were the murdochs
okay buddy very nice very good you don't
want to spend the summer the grocery
store or prepping meals let Factor do
the cooking for you yeah you keep
crushing your health goals Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit delivers nutritious meals straight
to your door it's the easiest way to
stay on track while saving tons of time
I've tried their stuff it's pretty damn
good oh yeah I like them I love the
smoothies they're good I'm a big fan
love Factor always fresh never Frozen
takes two minutes to prepare yeah I mean
every I had a ton of these and they're
all really good you need an extra boost
to support your Wellness goals this
summer try Protein Plus meals with 30
grams of protein or more per serving you
don't have time to cook you don't always
have you don't want to waste super
amount of money uh doing seamless yeah
all those hidden charges you order a
[__] Italian sub it's 47 exactly
exactly where the hell is the money
going Factor meals come in a variety of
Lifestyle options if you're vegan
vegetarian keto calorie counting there's
something delicious waiting for you head
to factor meals.com
drunk50 and use coat use the code drunk
50 to get 50 off your first box that's a
lot that's it I mean that's big some of
these discounts you're not getting that
so 50 off
that's code drunk 50 at factorymeals.com
drunk50 50 off your first box that is a
great deal hey
hey babe just already made your ball
s it's time to do something about that
face that ugly mug manscaped has just
announced a brand new beard hedger Pro
kit good to mix those up you don't want
to shave your face with something that
smells like your taint the beard hedger
gives you 20. uh hair cutting lengths
all at the turn of a dial no more
changing out attachments and it's
waterproof so you can shave in Katrina
and since manscape wants you to have all
the tools for the job they're throwing
in a beard brush comb scissor just to
make you look like a million bucks tell
them how fat eight get 20 off and free
shipping with the code drunk at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping at manstate manscape.com and
use code drunk the manscaped beard
hedger Pro kit the premier solution to
face grooming yeah hey folks word we
might be drunk is brought to you by
tushy hello
Taco Tuesday was a great time but let's
be honest now things are rough down
there thank God for hello tushy the
bidet that keeps things clean no matter
what junk you put in your body you got
to use tushy to wipe that b-hole clean
especially now with the uh the uh what's
it called fornicating in the you know
the old uh eat in the back door if you
know what I mean that's very popular
these days and you don't want to have a
nice snail Trail back there and you
definitely don't have a couple of shreds
of TP and a peanut and a piece of corn
so get yourself some tushy folks and
clean that back porch because people
want to go in there yeah
so the hello tissue bidet cleans two
times better than wiping and prevents
poop particles from spreading to your
hands and everything you touch it
attaches to your existing toilet
requiring no electricity or additional
plumbing and it cut toilet paper usage
by 80 percent Save the Planet you Kooks
if you do the math tushy pays for itself
in just a few months every hello tushy
bidet attachment comes with a 60-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12-month
warranty with over a hundred thousand
five star reviews see why millions of
people already love hello tushy and be
part of taking care of business the
cleaner way go to hellotushy.com forward
slash drunk and use promo code drunk to
get 10 off plus free shipping on your
bid day order on your first one ten
percent off that's hellotushy.com
drunk for 10 off get on it folks
we should do news stories he's a he's a
a joke Smith well you got one of my
favorite jokes ever the one about the
sign up to be a detective
detective yeah
oh Joe because I went online to become a
private detective it was a private
detective School online and I paid
online that I never heard from them
again
so um I thought this is either uh how's
it Go America either I just got ripped
off I discovered it's my first case yeah
that's a great [__] joke I believe
that's in your first Fallon yeah yeah
that's a great set check that out you
still do late night sets you're like one
of the few comics where like your
material works well for a late night so
yeah it's like you know it's like an old
school type of Comedy Mark and I love
that too yeah oh yeah getting together
because we're all good and like we're
good in five minutes yes yes which is
rare now once you get to know me I suck
but for five minutes because we're all
of the uh I think we're all of the
mindset it's like hit him hard yeah and
then get the confidence with the first
joke yes and then just like every seven
seconds and then even after the seven
seconds you still look at the joke and
go well is there a punchline on the way
in yes you know exactly I think we all
look jackhammed with them like four
times really hard and then I'm like I'm
done
you get the light yeah
no I agree because I think with Club
combo buddy you have to you have to win
them over that's like half the battle to
getting them to trust they oh this guy
we should listen to him right yeah but
how are you finding guys because you
guys have followings now big following
so how has it changed like on the road
where it's like you had to earn it like
that and now people know you yeah and
there is that better is it better it's
nice but it's also bittersweet because
you're like is this good or you guys
just like me you guys are into me and
like my act and know me and get my
Cadence or is this actually funny so
then you gotta try it again in front of
strangers right yeah
that's totally true mark because uh you
get they get that pop sometimes because
they know your Rhythm and they know you
and and that's why you got to try it I
think at the seller where they they
don't know you oh yeah you know so yeah
it's it's
but you were saying like we were talking
off air where it's like you can come at
them with something edgy and it's if
it's your crowd they already know you
yeah so it's like you don't need that
much of a setup yes but if they don't
know you you come off looking like a
psycho unless you Pat it yeah on both
sides of the joke like it's hard to open
with a holocaust joke you're right
you're not your crap right yes which
gets annoying because you're like no no
this is good I know I know it's jarring
for you guys because you don't know me
but this is good so it does get annoying
but I get it they don't know you so
they're like whoa is this a Nazi you
know well you gotta earn it right I mean
even for your crap it's funny where like
even for I think if I'm on the road even
for the crowd that comes to see me I I
do have to to some degree earn it
because not all like most of them are
fans but sometimes they like they bring
a friend sure sure but you placement
still matters like you don't want to
come out too hard it's like it's like
going out on a date and immediately
you're like sex right right you have to
you have to be like so what do you like
somebody so you kind of you know and if
you've been dating a couple weeks
but if you're I still find that you have
to like kind of like I have an abortion
joke I'm like let me put it at like
minute 18. let me like build up maybe
some dating stuff up top maybe some
lighter stuff yeah just just ease into
it work into it chronologically
that's hilarious and I close on getting
arrested in Oklahoma
that's my closer you pull up one of
Mike's jokes here play it I love I'm a
big fan of I also think your album is
one of the best I think that you have if
you haven't heard Mike's album the worst
kind of thoughtful there's a 10 minute
bus chunk it's just all about the bus
and it's one of the best bits I I just
every line is is incredible yeah like
they said this without you here so oh
yes that's been said without you here
and muscle confusion yeah I believe one
like album of the year with a couple
things and that is so good it's tight as
a drum thank you it has a cheese cave as
a cheesecake is it tight is a German
landlord sphincter yeah
I'm a huge boxing fan I love all kinds
of boxing and I was watching this one
fight it was a female fighter and her
brother was the promoter and they were
interviewing her and they're like how
did you start fighting and it's a tragic
story she goes um when I was young I
watched my father hit my mother it was
too weak to do anything about it so I
learned to fight and it never happened
again
I'm like wow that's pretty powerful
then I thought
that the brother
the promoter
grew up in the same home
so he must have saw the same thing and
thought to himself
I can sell tickets to this
now that's so great because what's
impressive about that bit obviously it's
a funny joke but there's a lot of
information to to get to the audience
there you know and that is the way you
made it so simple and accessible that's
a skill on its own but usually I don't
have the patience to get into the bit I
need a joke into the [__] sure there
was no joke into that yeah so it's like
I realize in some bits like yeah because
I'll see some guys just have the
patience and then wait for the payoff
and that's also valuable so it's just
like there was usually I like that joke
on the way in I agree there was I
couldn't get one off in there you know
it needs to be informational
yes yeah eight seconds of of setup yeah
but that's not a that's not a lot right
you know and the fact that it was so
much information so concisely and so
simply that's a skill on its own right
so I don't even think you needed the job
I like a joke set up too but you know
what I mean I think it's actually uh I
don't know how you guys feel about it
but I feel like it was it was they're
like a stage fright thing that's
developing it's like punch it up every
seven seconds because you don't wanna I
don't want to sit in silence yeah
neither yeah but I feel that in your
comedy like you're very much like you
feel guilty wasting even like a word
right it's a great thing but yes there's
also a time where you're like [__] man
you could take a deep breath like you
earned it yeah yeah you could take a
deep breath and and look we talk about
placement for an hour and yeah you if I
do a story I usually do a like one at
least one or two long stories per hour
and I'll I put them at the end right
it's kind of like all right this is
where it goes yeah well I feel like I
can prove and you're like I remember a
tell Once In the late night set says
this first joke and it kills me goes
I've proven I'm funny and it's like
that's kind of what it is you're like
okay I've proven I can do well here like
give me a minute to to let this longer
one build up to a bit right right you
know yeah yeah he earned it well I
realized on the road when I first
started headlining that it's like
you I just had such a New York mentality
where where it's like you just go up and
just just uh machine gun them with jokes
and it's like I realize like oh they're
there to see you yeah like even if they
don't know you they're there to see you
so it's like kind of relax into the
rapport with them and you're you are
you're armed with all of the jokes
already you're right they're not going
anywhere you could use them at any time
you want but instead of just going up
there like a city set and just being
like boom boom boom boom just like relax
into them get to like get the Rapport
going you don't have to rush into it and
then drop the jokes in wherever you see
fit because yeah but don't I mean I I'm
speaking personally I have that fear
they'll get bored because stand up is
and kind of boring it's a guy on stage
talking or a girl on state talk it's not
a ton of some guys will hump in a stool
or doing backflips but for us it's just
this yeah so I I think you gotta Hammer
them but maybe I'm wrong
no that it that's I just think like the
mentality of the road is like also it's
15 minutes in a city uh so you gotta get
up there and just like you have to prove
it and then you have to like oh hit them
with like when you have an hour it's
like all right yeah so it's just like
let's take our time right you know what
I mean that was so much easier like I
always feel bad like whoever's opening
doing like 20. everyone's like that's
the kill spot I'm like yeah I guess but
it's like 20 minutes is harder it's
harder to do 20 minutes in an hour right
I think if the crowd's if it's your
crowd yeah it's a good crowd right right
right right absolutely yeah I want to
[__] do I want a feature usually come
off and tell you that they're a
headliner they just weren't down
but also you gotta think Columbus Ohio
or Denver Colorado they're not as
fast-paced as New York anyway right so
to if you're kind of slowing down they
don't even notice it right right well
that's a New York mentality everywhere
you go into a [__] dime yeah sit down
go sit down yes exactly you go to a
diner in the South they're like they're
like we'll get to it you ever go to a
salad place here I mean you gotta know
you go down the line like uh uh olives
yeah mushroom if you stumble they're
like come on you [__] you're like wait
what what are we doing here
this is legitimately good it's so good
not bad right yeah oh yeah
but yeah they uh everything is faster
but they make it up for you in the South
and other places with um kindness
you know what I mean so everything takes
longer but in the middle of it taking
longer they're actually nice to you they
go how's your day right and they really
want their how is your day it's like all
right you know what I mean like it's
good it's like the weather we're getting
here and they're like they sink into a
conversation totally whereas in here
it's just like they nobody people look
through you yes yeah that's the biggest
thing hardest thing that people have
adjusted to New York is like sitting on
the Subways just like looking through
people yeah yeah just because there's so
much stimulus coming in and you have to
like yes wall some of it off I find this
so up here so it's like yeah yeah but
like you know when you're on the road
and like can you do our podcast at the
club at four then you gotta show at
seven a show at 9 30. then you gotta
sell merch after the first show you got
to meet the host you got to meet the
feature it's a lot of stimulus and
you're like I should be saving some of
this for the show what am I doing here
well that's what I always remember with
these clubs where they have you do like
morning radio and like you do the show
Thursday night and then they're like all
right morning radio is that uh pick up 6
a.m yes look I flew in yesterday and I'm
going to bed at three yes Wired from the
Thursday nights and maybe a few pups
yeah and then you're just like you're on
radio like everyone goes on muscle
relaxers on one of them and I I had to
have like a mandra pull it down that was
just like making no sense oh wow
but I'm like this is what they made me
be here and I'm just on there they're
like I'm like and they're just like okay
I'm like two shows tonight and they're
like no one's coming
based on this sales pitch where he's
slurring this guy's the next Hedberg I'm
like worried about you it sucks to be
called the the next Hedberg not for your
comedy yeah exactly exactly uh yeah you
know uh those morning radios and then of
course you do two shows at night and
you're just exhausted yeah you're just I
mean it's like I'm not complaining it's
a great [__] gig but it's one of the
things you're like yeah you need to
conserve energy oh yeah I always check
the morning radio with uh 6 a.m as I
judge whether to have coffee or not and
the way I judge it is like okay it's 6
a.m it's like how long am I on for yeah
and if they go you're on for the whole
morning or you're on for an hour because
I want to be on as long as possible
because if we're gonna if I'm gonna get
up that early of course let's try to
sell some tickets right I mean so keep
me on as long as possible I hang through
the break I'll do trap whatever you guys
yeah but if I'm getting up if I have to
get up for five minutes I'm not drinking
coffee I don't want to go back to sleep
yeah good point now can you guys sleep I
can't nap no I don't I don't know I can
really yeah I can sleep if I don't drink
the coffee and I'm doing five minutes I
just and they're fine oh yeah Mike that
get on here and you have a better
t-shirt it's like all right man thanks
for stopping by then I leave and I'll go
back to sleep yeah I had I'm only an
[__] when I get two hours of sleep
and that's like there's that clip of me
that well I'm just [__] with the
morning people and it's because I got
two hours of sleep I was we flew from uh
LA to Sacramento
uh like a couple weeks ago and it was
just a long day it was like you know you
do the shows in La then you wake up the
next morning and you got to take the
early flight to Sacramento because you
can't chance it right so we land we get
at the gig we don't get a hotel because
we're like let's just chill at the venue
all day and it's like a beautiful
theater The Crest theater but it's not a
good theater for like hanging right
right downstairs it's it's like I used
to live in an apartment like this where
like all the doors don't go up to the
ceiling
and that's what all the green rooms were
so I literally I hear my video guy James
just like belching I hear a feeder on
like FaceTiming with his kids every door
slamming all the people are like
slamming the door and I'm like trying to
sleep and I can't sleep and at one point
I just get up and I go shut the [__] up
[__] everyone's like what the
[__] and I was like sorry and I just
like go back into bed but everyone shut
up I was able to sleep all right only
time I'm taking a nap in like years wow
I don't nap yeah
I did it because I was so [__] tired
and I was sick so I was like but uh no
if I like on a flight I'll like doze off
sometimes but I don't no I don't but it
takes so long to nap like a 10 minute
nap or 20 minute nap takes me like three
hours because I have to like shut down I
have to turn the lights down I have to
lay there look at your phone a little
bit jerk uh you know you get it
conserving energies people don't
understand that um that early morning
flight because you don't want to chance
it what you just what you said and
that's really the truth it's like I
could leave it two and get there at four
and then the show is seven but the thing
if the flight gets delayed at all
um I could miss the show you know I mean
yeah I'm screwed so it's like it's
either that two o'clock or a six a.m
it's like I gotta take the 6 a.m to be
safe before you know take the two I did
it for the Knicks game I came back into
the 6 a.m flight to go to the Knicks
game on Sunday and uh I was like running
on fumes I was like [__] I'm getting
drunk yeah yeah that's great but see the
the other end of that is it's the Knicks
game yeah so you get that to look
forward to I was so pumped yeah we lost
but I was so funny
yeah but the drink it helps it does wake
you up it's temporary but it helps when
you're on fumes I was with staff and we
saw we saw A-Rod going into the building
and Adam Glenn you know you know he's
like you guys should annoy A-Rod and I
was like that's a great idea so we just
stop and I just run up to a rod and
we're like yo A-Rod can we take a
picture with you and he's like sure and
his handlers are like [__] they're like
trying to push us away we got one pick
off nice it's just a great pick of stop
lurking behind A-Rod yeah ah trying to
sniff from JLo
uh also the thing about the five minute
radio this is what kills me and this is
where I sound like Mark cuntman Norman
but it's not just five minutes of radio
it's getting picked up by the club
manager who wants to chit chat at 6 20
in the morning and he's like so how's uh
New York that's good oh yeah all right
and then you get to the radio and then
you gotta chit chat with the makeup Lady
you got a chit chat with the dog lady in
the in the green room with you who's
like makeup for radio well I'm sorry I'm
morning TV TV and then there's the dog
lady then there's the chef guy who's
gonna make this the uh the skewers today
and all that it's like it's just so much
extra [__] it's not it's like the guest
spot can I do five minutes on your show
all right yeah it's just five minutes
but then you gotta sit in the green room
with them you gotta hang out with the
guy he feels weird so he's doubling down
on the convo because he doesn't want any
silence and and then he go then the guy
comes in for the the sound check guy
comes and he goes is he doing a guest
set on the second show and now it's
awkward so you gotta be like okay the
whole thing's Brewing the morning TV
thing is the best when you're in the
green room with like whatever like you
know lady like she's like I'm coming on
after you to show a cooking recipe and
you're like oh that's nice yes and then
you come in afterwards and you just see
the look of Horror
she doesn't look you the same she's like
you're not a good person yeah but you
guys are the best because you make the
most of that you realize what the
opportunity oh you gotta do you make the
most of the morning radio and if they
don't have you back like you guys
they're never pleased with us no never
but that's why it's good that's why it's
good don't have me on if you don't want
me to be me yeah you know who am I
Barbara Walters no I'm going in no
you're alive
but do you ever do that thing where it's
like you go to another town and you're
like I wonder what it in an alternate
universe what my life would be like if I
just had a regular job and I lived here
and how that would be suicide
no
that's a good question
what would you do if you had to have a
gig outside of Comedy yet ideally I'm
not saying you're qualified for every
gig but if you could pick it Sports
something sports related sports
announcer writer yeah writer announcer
like maybe uh maybe even like a sports I
don't know something Sports okay how
about you I would go UPS guy
no office you're outside you got a car
with no door you got shorts on you might
[__] a couple of housewives with the
packages
that would be mine most of these
packages are left outside these days I
feel true but it's my [__] door man
there we go go and I get on some ring
doorbells maybe I'll get go viral I'll
do like a dance or something
that's an idea actually uh like to go to
Martin scorsese's house and hopefully as
a ring
that's great yeah body yeah that's good
just keep going give me the money you
[__] it's like that's gotta fit
somewhere into a score Marty just he
opens the door he's like you got the
game yeah
hugs you so that's an idea these ring
lights that's a good way to audit that's
not bad I would be I would actually be a
tick tock dancer no
be a big dancer all right no I can't
dance my thing is um you know I would
own a small if I had like a town in the
middle of the country something I would
own a small business you'd have to
because that's kind of what we're doing
now it's like small business you would
throw everything behind that that would
be your life that's what we're doing
with this is yeah throwing everything
into it so uh but I like the um my
fantasy is a food truck is a food truck
guy because I feel like once you get the
permits you know I know there's some red
tape with the permits but you could just
go anywhere it's like where where people
construction site at lunch and then uh
people getting out of work like boom you
set up a set up there and sell and then
if you just if you need extra money it's
like wherever the club's let out at two
in the morning oh yes right so just a
limited item but Jack the prices and you
can always it's just like a moving money
machine yeah you just make money good
point yeah yeah get the drunks but you
gotta get the promise that's a
Providence I think that uh Federal Hill
it's like it's like people would come
out from drunk and it's just like
there's just food trucks lined up and
it's just they just yeah they have
really good food trucks really good
Providence kind of next to the cellar
there's that food truck when you come
off the subway from West 4th it's like
spaghetti oh yeah that's right food
truck I'm too scared to eat there isn't
it good I don't know I got a truck maybe
you got maybe you guys want to put me as
a um reporter
go try it and tape A short segment and
then send it back to you guys there's a
Mexican food truck on uh right outside
of uh Christopher Street the one so good
yeah shout out to them I forget I forget
oh yeah they are really good very good
ten dollar burrito tacos tacos are
maggots very good they always have a
line yeah it's like a great late night
great spot surprisingly good too because
you like a Mexican food I feel like New
York is like we're just not we have so
many good Cuisines but we just we have
good Mexican spots but that's like not
our thing New York right right like you
know Texas California yeah fruit yeah
for Houston Houston Mexicans San Antonio
is amazing food San Diego yeah L.A I
find New York is great for food because
I came from Philly I started comedy in
Philly and New York has great food but
you're going to pay for it yeah as soon
as they realize they have great food
everybody Jacks the prices up and it's
like a five-star Michelin whatever but
in Philly in South Philly where the
Italians are it's like there's corner
places that are delicious and cheap just
because they take pride in their food
interesting New Orleans is similar like
you can't get Creole here I've tried it
so that's another one that for some
reason also barbecue too kind of Barbie
there's a couple but like yeah of course
there's like a few I know people are
gonna like get the conversation Dallas
Barbecue yeah Dinosaur Barbecue yeah
like oh dude like Kansas City barbecue
or like Oklahoma or Texas yeah so good
Texas St Louis St Louis Barbecue
Nashville but
you can't get Grill but in New Orleans
you can go to some hole in the wall
Place get a po boy like a shrimp po boy
it's the best thing you've ever eaten
but it's the culture yeah yeah but I
gotta go to Southfield I've never been
to Southfield that's where Rocky runs
through yeah yeah oh yeah I gotta go
there is it still Italian I think so
yeah wow so I think a lot of Italians
move to South Jersey because they wanted
a house in space and all that but I
think that property taxes went up in all
the South Jersey Washington Township
Italians move back to the south building
so I think it's like uh I think all
right
the food is unreal but you should go to
this place called I dated a girl down
there and I worked down there and we
used to go to this place called Evelyn
and Shanks I don't know if it's still
there I doubt it but it was just a hole
in the wall it was like three tables and
like three Italian old Italian women
cooking I love it like a have a fried
meatball platter broccoli Rob
ugly rob a salad dude you just want a
fat lady with a dirty apron that's all
you want out of a restaurant you want to
see like fat tits with a little sweat
yes yeah maybe a hair net she calls you
Hun well she tells you like calm down
yeah it's coming I like a sassy man it
was this place in AC called Tony's
Baltimore Grill oh yes I love it those
old Italian ones that reminds me of the
South Philly place I love this okay
there's something about it and also like
I remember one week I was there and I
just got loaded there like every night
you'd order like a Jack and Coke it
would come in a pint glass yeah five
bucks like this is a [__] problem
right here but uh but the food is like
great food was great yeah and they were
open all my is pre-covered but they were
open 24 hours yeah all the people with
all the wait staff and stuff from the
casinos would get off work and go there
you get some real drugs to society there
yeah I brought one of them
my friend Adam was like really a [__]
problem he's like a degenerate Gambler I
literally he's like that dude where you
know you go to a casino and he's and
you're playing a gig and he's just there
yeah oh I saw you doing a gig here so I
figured I'm like oh boy yeah oh yeah oh
Adam hey so you worked did you ever work
the trop stop down there uh-uh okay so
no you did yeah I [__] I got uh scam
there right they didn't pay me when it
was going out right yeah okay so you
remember you have to you'd have to stay
in that Nucky Thompson Building yeah
where Boardwalk Empire yeah I remember
the real bill I remember walking into
that building [__] face and just seeing
a giant cockroach and stomping it and
just collapsing onto the bed I think my
memory of that weekend that's like a
Noir movie yeah
I'm gonna stop the Cockroach I just
walked over the bed yeah it's really
great but the thing is is it would be
the Trap was across the street and what
you would have to do is and you don't
know any of this beforehand when you do
it for the first time so it's
complicated but you drive your car
around you take your suitcase up or or
you drive the car around and just you
have to let it sit there and then go
across the street to get the keys no
then come back and then put your luggage
up and then drive your car to the garage
but when my point is whenever you would
uh drive up the security guard for that
place would come out and be like you
can't park
every single time it was a new guy just
waving his hands going you can't park
here you can't leave your car here and
it's like I know dude I have to go over
get the keys and come back but it's like
after a while I just leaned into it and
dispute would be like because people
like sometimes with these jobs they just
they have information so it's like you
gotta let them you gotta let them get it
out yes so he goes you can't park here I
go I can't can't and he goes no you
cannot park here it's like oh thank you
thank you for letting me know I'm gonna
can I just leave here for a couple
seconds and then go get the he goes all
right that's good you know what I mean
but it's like it's like they feel
empowered right flip it on them yeah I'm
never doing that good because you work
with two other Comics right we've got
three headliner show yeah I remember one
of the guys I was working with was just
like he was just betting on first off we
got scammed on money so we didn't get
paid for the week but also the guy I was
working with was like a crazy Sports
Gambler so he would just bet on like
meaningless baseball games that you
can't bet on baseball there's 162 games
in the season they're like they're
meaningless the games yeah so every time
he'd look down he'd be like on this
phone he'd be like can't catch a [__]
brain there's a whole week and then by
the end of the week I was like wow he
really can't catch a break yeah we got
[__] but uh yeah but it was always it
was always how they would not pay you as
as it was like you'll get it in two
weeks right it was always that yeah
which just means never it meant never at
the end I think when he was going out of
business I had such a [__] week agent
at the time he was such a [__] weasel
I remember telling him and he's like
well these things happen I was like
that's not what you say
I was like well you got to do something
and he's just like no I'm like well you
got like you can't commission me for a
while I was like that's not how it works
I was like wow these guys are a piece
this guy's a piece of [__] you fired him
of course yeah these things happen
how do you like it no it was really uh
that was like a classic you know it's a
bad gig at a casino when they won't put
you up in the casino
you're not even they're not even giving
you a hotel room yeah what kind of deal
do they have like how much are they
shaving off the top they can't comp you
a [__] room right you know because
you work a good Casino like they take
care of it yes casinos are that's the
hospitality business totally you go to
Vegas like you won't get better service
than Vegas you ever take that deal where
they're like we'll pay you in chips
don't take no what I heard they do that
right Mark they do it but they're gonna
do this they're talking about lays
sorry I'm in joke mode
[__] break
but you know we were talking about the
South Philly plays the Creole but you
know what New York has that I worry is
going away is the diners you guys got
these hole in the wall [__] box diners
the greasy spoon they're so good they're
dropping like flies yeah I feel like
they're not not around as uh there's not
as plentiful the flies are in The
Omelette no I love uh I love a greasy
spoon I love a good like something about
like an omelet on the road too or like
two eggs and bacon or like or like you
know just [__] crispy ass hash browns
yeah a cup of coffee sit there all day
you read the paper we go to La bogiere
on uh on Hudson and it's It's gotta be a
health violation in there but it's so
good
I best feeling ever is when you when
you're like a regulated Diner and the
guy will just come out like I know what
you would like yes yes we have that guy
Paco I know what you like Marco
feels good to be seen yes it does but I
like that breakfast all day and then
like I'm open late oh yeah it just
doesn't happen anymore I feel like kovid
gave people an excuse to be like yeah
now we're closing at 10 right and any
Starbucks in any hotel it's like never
never open from 9 10 to 9. it's like 2
p.m how about every [__] road coffee
shop they're like we close it too and
you're like people like coffee after two
yes people work at night why wouldn't
you put one person there just to make
the money say we will about Hampton Inn
they got coffee around the clock in the
lobby you can take as much as you want
you take 10 cups if you want I'm feeling
bad I use a little bit of that hazelnut
creamer I'm a real [__] piggy you're
living oh French vanilla oh that's what
killed Kirsty alley
cheesecake oh
it's just straight sugar it's all sugar
it's like oil and sugar yeah I'm just
like oh I'm in a coffee I want to be an
adult and then you're like let's put
some cake batter cream on there yeah see
that's what the dime the diners are
leaving in the 7-Elevens are taking over
7-Eleven
they're terrible I mean it's tough too
so it's like I feel like they didn't
come in for the diners they came in for
like those corner stores yeah yeah right
classic like also like how many [__]
vape shops yeah I know I hate The Vape
it's like literally like how I don't
feel like people is vaping gonna be
forever is that a thing I guess it will
be I think it's cheap but overhead and
they make money but yeah I hate them
they're everywhere and they got the neon
lights flashing it's a new box store I
guess right it used to be the pipes and
then also then um there's a bunch of uh
if the screen is broken on your phone
stores yeah
three uh three aging white guys don't
like change
[Laughter]
[Music]
my gears yeah I should have finished
that wall
that's really what this is turning into
all right we gotta wrap this up where
this turns into a 60 minutes
Mickey Rooney you got any you got some
dates to plug yeah I have two big ones
which is um
Rosemont Illinois yeah good room please
come out to that one uh and uh Levity
Live in Nyack nice so those two dates
right yeah so um so Nyack and Chicago
um the May 26th and 27th for Chicago
June 8th through 10th at uh Levity Live
nice and uh please watch the special on
YouTube Mike Vecchio on the attractives
and follow me on social media at Comic
Mike V I'm putting out content
constantly one of the best Comics great
joke really and and one of the best
dudes as well I really appreciate you
guys having me on like I know I called
uh texted you Sam to uh and I appreciate
you really having me on to hang out
number one and to promote also one of
one of the best Comics since since I as
long as I can remember prolific and uh
in a [__] great dude so it's nice
nice always nice when it's both a lot of
people we have on here and they're funny
but they're pieces of [__] yeah you got
that right successful
success
you were the first guy I ever saw the
seller by the way I went to the seller
when I first moved here and it was
Geraldo oh my God it was a tell it was
you and Norton that was a show wow and
it was a banger and then somebody I
can't remember somebody I think he's not
doing anymore but you killed and I
brought a friend he was like that guy
who looked like a cop never stopped
telling jokes that's awesome because
everyone else kind of geralda was
hammered right right you know Norton
[__] with a guy in the crowd but you
just boom boom boom it was great that's
an insane lineup yeah that's really
[__] cool
Good Times um when does this come out
okay all right let's see before you do
your dates yeah Sam this comes out May
21st what's your prediction on the
playoffs oh we'll see if it comes true
by the way uh my prediction dude you
know I'm [__] I know but I want to
hear how you think it's gonna play out
my prediction is I'm mulling on the
Knicks baby always man that's not a good
prediction I bet with my heart and I
live by the [__] sword brother I
don't think that makes sense but you
know what I'm saying brother this is
gonna be you and me can't catch a break
yeah
all right so may yeah June 1st in
Hampton Beach oh New Hampshire yeah
Portland Maine uh mash and Tucket
Connecticut don't know what that is the
casino I guess there we go Richmond
Virginia perley's baby hey my favorite
Jewish Spot Great Dane which yeah uh
Greensboro Asheville Charlotte uh
Knoxville Memphis Tennessee on June 9th
June 10th in Birmingham June 11th in
Chattanooga 9th 10th 11th three
different cities
that's impressive you got a bus three
nights we're on the bus for that one
yeah June 13th in Nashville the rhyming
it's great June 22. oh you're doing the
Ryman yeah wow wow that's a beauty one
of the great venues in America a late
show added at the Paramount Theater yes
also a great venue yeah
Santa Fe San Antonio Houston you get the
deal tickets on samrail.com shows and uh
and Bodega cat and I do believe tell me
if I'm wrong here mark
your comedy special is out
no not yet not yet not yet I think uh
July okay we got some time so and this
second special I directed for Stavros
it's about to hit a million views wow
it's on YouTube four nights in New York
City nice one of the best one of our
favorites so funny uh and
am I am my next brother now that Giannis
got knocked out once the Bucks lose stav
is all in on the Knicks so there you go
I'll be uh I'll be in uh this weekend
when this comes out I think I'll be in
Austin doing that Mother Ship nice I'm
gonna check that out and then I'm going
straight to Australia from there oh my
God see in Sydney Adelaide Perth
Melbourne uh New Zealand
Brisbane Austin is Sydney that's not a
direct no it's gonna be ugly I'm coming
back to New York then flying out oh wow
but it's gonna be a nightmare of a
flight but I'm staying there for a while
and uh we're adding shows like crazy so
jump on board get on it and then
announcing by the time this comes out
I'll have some uh my theater tour
announced and uh we'll go from there
doing all the big cities I'll see you in
hell thank you Mike Bodega whiskey.com
yes
we're making moves by the way I was just
in Texas I'm holding one up in the
soccer store how crazy is that amazing
it's in the store bought a couple
bottles because I want them to know
shit's going down yeah no products
moving there you go but uh yeah beer Jew
you got anything
beerjew is in New York for a while come
see me at good Room Brooklyn and Green
Point hell yeah I'll be here for a while
and so I go to Australia as well oh okay
well there you go all right Sally thank
you Peters
quiff it up we love you Peters we love
you all at home thank you for uh for
listening and uh and tell a friend there
you go keep drinking
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
[Music]
we might be true